all of our enemies see that this
president is a weakling and so they've
moved and putin is moving so here is a
joe biden yesterday saying that he
guesses that probably putin will move
into ukraine i mean why not he probably
has to says joe biden
i'm not so sure he has uh
is certain what he's going to do my
guess is he will move in
he has to do something
he has to do something you know later
biden tries to back off that maybe we
don't know yet maybe he'll do something
maybe he won't but he has to do my guess
is he will move mike
why not just give him the green light
okay it gets worse it gets worse so joe
biden is trying to explain that there
will be consequences if vladimir putin
goes into ukraine
but
he says that if vladimir putin does not
go full bore into ukraine like he
doesn't march into kiev
if he's if you just go if it's just the
tip
then it's fine
just the tip isn't isn't really isn't
really an inv it's kind of a minor
incursion it's like a minor incursion
you know like bill clinton and monica
lewinsky minor incursion
here here is joe biden
opening i mentioned april glaspie before
the secret the undersecretary of state
in the middle east during the the h.w
bush administration who suggested that
the united states might not do anything
if iraq invaded kuwait
and there's controversy over whether she
basically precipitated the iraqi
invasion or not if vladimir putin
invades ukraine you can attribute it to
this comment above all others this is
the president of the united states in a
full public press conference saying that
as long as vladimir putin only commits a
minor incursion there might not be
consequences
here was joe biden yesterday
i think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having to fight about
what to do and not do etc
it's one thing it's a minor incursion
it's one thing it's a it's a minor
incursion not just welcome just open the
gate man
and by the way according to cnn the the
entire government of ukraine is now in a
state of full-scale
meltdown panic because that is joe biden
just offering ukraine up on a platter
because vladimir putin is going to say
well what if it's not a minor incursion
first of all there's no such thing as
minor incursion on american territory if
mexico just walked across the southern
border of the united states and took
over some of the border counties of of
texas
but they didn't take all of texas just
just like a little bit would we consider
that a minor like in what circumstances
is it considered a minor incursion for
any country to cross the sovereign
border of another country militarily
how does that even work
how is that a minor like that's that's
crazy towns what he is saying you know
sudetenland minor incursion
when in human history has it been
considered a minor incursion to just
cross the border of another sovereign
state
but there's joe biden saying by the way
he doubled down on this he was asked
again later to clarify and what he said
was you know nato's divided we can't get
the europeans on board to do anything if
it's a minor incursion so you know we
really i can't really say that we're
going to do much over here because you
know if he takes the nuts then he takes
the nuts you know like
to say that out loud in a press
conference in front of the world like
vladimir putin must just be laughing his
ass off
at this weakling
so this necessitated the nightmares gen
saki coming in
after presumably downing all of her
edibles that she keeps for emergency
circumstances according to red seas over
twitter
it necessitated her showing up
and releasing a statement here is the
statement quote president biden has been
clear with the russian president if any
russian military forces move across the
ukrainian border that's a renewed
invasion and it will be met with a swift
severe and united response from the
united states and our allies president
biden also knows from long experience
that the russians have an extensive
playbook of aggression short of military
action including cyber attacks and
paramilitary tactics and he affirmed
today that those acts of russian
aggression will be met with a decisive
reciprocal and united response no he did
precisely the opposite
he did exactly the opposite we played
the tape of it
it's fun to watch history being
rewritten in real time he literally said
yesterday nato is not united nato is
divided he literally said yesterday that
a minor incursion might be different
than a major full-scale russian invasion
that is joe biden giving a green light
to like putin would be an idiot not to
walk across the border at this point
why wouldn't he
hey seriously what what is the downside
for vladimir putin what are you gonna do
to him joe you can't get the germans on
board to sanction nordstrom too
not over a minor incursion it's um
incredible stuff okay so here's the
bottom line joe biden's presidency is
failing on every conceivable level which
leaves him one option that option is to
complain about republicans so now he's
trying to blame republicans he has a
majority in the senate he's a majority
in the house he's the president of the
united states he can't get anything done
because he decided to pursue a
completely partisan insane agenda
that has failed in every respect
naturally that means he's going to blame
republicans good luck with this pitch
i did not anticipate that there'd be
such a
stalwart effort to make sure that the
most important thing was that president
biden didn't get anything done
think about this what are republicans
for
what are they for
they mean one thing they're for alrighty
you ready here are a few things that
republicans are for they are for lower
taxes lower regulations not shutting
down the entire country because of your
idiotic coveted protocols they're
against vax mandates by the way being
against the thing is also being for
another thing okay being against fax
mandates being means being for personal
freedom being against your garbage
spending plans means being in favor of a
free market economy being against your
foreign policy means being in favor of a
muscular american foreign policy
trying to blame republicans for your own
failures i love this he's like who could
have foreseen i i don't know i never
thought that republicans might have
really you've been in the senate since
the senate didn't exist he's been in the
senate since 1622.
and this guy didn't it never occurred to
him that is president of the united
states you might run into some political
opposition it's incredible okay so
here's the bottom line failed president
failed administration no ability to turn
things around and he happens to be a
babbling incoherent fool
that's where we are
good luck we have three more years of
this gang
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment